[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 sur TV
78 dans l'actualité de ce jeudi 14
septembre la justice confirme le renvoi
de 14 personnes en procède en l'affaire
de l'assassinat de Samuel Paty lui
majeur seront jugés devant les assis
spéciales 6 adolescents devant le
tribunal pour enfants dans l'actualité
également l'ancien président de la
République Nicolas Sarkozy qui était à
versailly hier pour dédicacer son
nouveau livre on fait le point dans
cette édition ce week-end ce sont les
40e journée européennes du patrimoine
dans les Yvelines les lieux à visiter ne
manquent pas la rédaction vous propose
sa sélection le roi de la forêt vous
accueille dans son royaume jusqu'au 1er
octobre l'Espace Rambouillet propose au
public de venir écouter le brame du cerf
un cri caractéristique de sa période de
reproduction immersion dans une balade
pédagogique à la découverte des secrets
de la vie de ses cervidés et puis
l'invité du 7 8 en deuxième partie à
l'approche des journées du patrimoine
focus sur le programme plus spécifique à
50 ans en Yvelines entre patrimoine
vivant et patrimoine du sport Lucie
Sauvageau responsable de l'action
culturelle au musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous dit tout
du nouveau dans la faire de l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty la cour d'appel de Paris
à confirmé le renvoi de 14 personnes en
procès du major seront jugés devant les
assis spéciales deux amis de la
saillants pour complicité d'assassinat
terroriste 6 autres personnes pour
association de malfaiteurs terroristes
criminels enfin 5 mineurs accusés
notamment d'avoir désigné Samuel Paty à
la saillant seront jugés devant le
tribunal pour enfants tout comme une
sixième adolescente elle pour
dénonciation calomnieuse il s'agit de
l'élève à l'origine du mensonge sur la
teneur d'un cours de Samuel Paty auquel
elle n'avait pas assisté le 16 octobre
2020 l'enseignant d'histoire-géographie
avait été poignardée puis décapité près
de son collège du bois d'aulne à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine le terroriste
avait été abattu par les forces de
l'ordre l'ancien président de la
République Nicolas Sarkozy était de
passage dans les Yvelines hier mercredi
13 septembre il est venu dédicacer son
deuxième livre sur ses mémoires dans la
librairie Gibert Versailles intitulé Le
Temps des combats il revient sur ses
années à l'Élysée c'est pas tellement la
suite c'est c'est le continuum du lien
que j'ai avec les Français
c'est l'histoire d'événements qu'on a
vécu ensemble et qui ont laissé de
grandes traces pour moi et qui je
l'espère ont laissé des trash c'est chez
tous ceux qui me lisent et c'est
toujours un bonheur de rencontrer les
lecteurs les chauffeurs de bus Keolis
sont lancé une grève illimitée depuis
mardi dernier il bloque l'entrée du site
de Montesson leur principal
revendication la réhabilitation de leur
prime d'intéressement et de
participation supprimées depuis 2022 ce
mouvement impact plus d'une dizaine de
lignes sur 90 chauffeurs 8 seraient non
grévistes ce soir l'équipe de France de
rugby affronte l'Uruguay pour son
deuxième match de Coupe du monde même si
la rencontre se joue à Lille vous pouvez
soutenir les Bleus dès 21h en direct des
Yvelines plusieurs villes du département
se sont mises aux couleurs du XV de
France comme Rambouillet et Versailles
ou des écrans géants ont été installés
[Musique]
musée jardin villa château pour cette
40e édition des Journées européennes du
patrimoine le département des Yvelines
vous offre un grand choix de
possibilités et comme chaque année le
château de Breteuil a choisi son
traditionnels balles la demeure des
contes de Perrault vous propose de
plonger au 19e siècle et d'entrée dans
la danse
c'est qu'ils vont faire danser les
spectateurs c'est à dire les personnes
qui viennent comme ça dans le château
peuvent aussi danser et en quelque sorte
d'apprendre les danses de l'époque cette
année deux thématiques ont été choisies
patrimoine vivant et patrimoine du sport
en amont des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 de nombreux
événements festifs mêlant les arts et le
sport auront lieu comme au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
on met en place différentes activités
sportives alors vélo évidemment avec le
cyclisme sur piste et le BMX et on ouvre
également les portes au grand public
pour visiter les installations du
bâtiment et les coulisses également au
cœur et inside de la préparation pour
les Jeux de Paris 2024 l'île de loisirs
de 50 ans de Yvelines propose aussi des
visites guidées à vélo samedi après-midi
de 14h30 à 16h30 toujours sur le plan
sportif le musée de la toile de jouets
organise un tournoi en famille avec du
croquet des jeux de quilles et de volant
et puis pour ceux qui sont plus adeptes
de patrimoine anciens la villa viardo a
Bougival sera inaugurée spécialement ce
week-end sélectionnez en 2018 par le
loto du patrimoine la demeure de la
fameuse cantatrice Pauline Viardot est
aujourd'hui méconnaissable
[Musique]
samedi dans les journées du patrimoine
en m'invité à les jouer à vieille église
en Yvelines le concert a lieu à 16h
[Musique]
à l'église je serai accompagné par
Francis Roudier qui est titulaire de
l'église des grandes orgues de l'église
sainte-jeanne-d'arves de Versailles et
Lorraine balsagète au violoncelle c'est
une super violoncelliste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un peu tout et vraiment je fais très
attention à jouer aussi bien du
classique Mozart bac Erik Satie et puis
ensuite on va se diversifier je joue
beaucoup de musique de films et ça ça
intéresse ça fait plaisir à énormément
de monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
un son rock et puissant l'Espace
Rambouillet situation champ propose aux
aventuriers en herbe de venir
s'émerveiller en écoutant le brame du
cerf un grimarquant le début de la
saison des amours pour ce roi de la
forêt ce soir-là la vingtaine de
participants accompagnés d'un guide a pu
s'approcher de ses hardes de sévidés
pendant environ deux heures toute
l'année le mâle et la femelle ils vont
pas du tout être mélangés et au moment
de la période de production il va y
avoir une une très forte hausse de
testostérone chez le mâle et c'est ça en
fait qui va pousser le mal à se
rapprocher des femelles pour la
reproduction donc la testostérone c'est
l'hormone sexuelle donc c'est ça qui va
produire une hausse de son envie de se
reproduire finalement
repoussez les adversaires marquez son
territoire et attirer les biches
silencieux le reste de l'année le cercle
à se faire entendre jusqu'à plusieurs
kilomètres avec son brame une période
très éprouvante pour lui pendant un mois
donc il va presque pas manger presque
pas dormir il sera tout le temps aux
aguets pour surveiller la les femelles
en chaleur va avoir les autres mâles
autour qui ne sont pas dominants qui
vont rester quand même autour pour ici
que de quand même se reproduire avec les
femelles en chaleur restante un autre
mal répond aux domino
ah oui il est juste en face entre le
début
jumelles photos pour immortaliser ce
moment privilégié les curieux de nature
ont pu s'approcher à une cinquantaine de
mètres de ces animaux en semi-liberté un
spectacle unique pour les petits et les
grands à l'approche de l'automne
on dirait un barrissement d'éléphant ou
un rugissement d'un lion
bien sûr c'est toujours une chance de
pouvoir aller en Afrique ou ailleurs de
voir des animaux en liberté mais il n'y
a pas besoin finalement d'aller aussi
loin pour partager des instants
exceptionnels de vie sauvage je
m'intéresse à la photo à l'évalière et
tout mais ici on peut les approcher
beaucoup plus près parce qu'ils sont un
peu habitués à voir les autres les
humains quoi et je trouve c'est
impressionnant une expérience à vivre le
matin ou le soir complété d'un petit
déjeuner ou d'un dîner au cœur du parc
rendez-vous jusqu'au 1er octobre 2023
pour entendre raisonner la magie de la
forêt
[Musique]
20h la nuit tombe et le hameau fournaise
de Chatou s'illumine pour cette
troisième édition le festival des
lumières impressionnistes invités les
passants à voyager vers le Japon car au
19e siècle les estampes japonaises ont
largement inspiré les impressionnistes
et donc on a créé des diptyque qui
permettent aux gens en fait de repérer
les similitudes dans les constructions
et c'est tout ce que le festival a voulu
mettre en oeuvre en fait à travers le
son et lumière les spectacles c'est de
montrer à quel point le Japon était une
influence féconde sur la culture
française à la fin du 19e et puis de
quelle manière aussi le Japon s'est
inspiré de la France donc vraiment c'est
le dialogue des cultures qu'on met à
l'honneur le tout sur un site
entièrement décoré avec des lampions
japonais des nénuphars lumineux et des
centaines de lumières des spectacles des
acrobaties étaient également au
programme on est sur un festival
impressionniste plus calme plus poétique
plus familiale aussi de plus en plus
important parce qu'on a on a la première
année on a été vite vraiment victime de
succès on pensait pas on a eu plus de
6000 personnes et c'est vrai que l'an
dernier autant pour time Isère à temps
on va dire pas très moi cet événement
festif est gratuit est en accès libre
rendez-vous l'année prochaine début
septembre pour contempler un nouveau
spectacle lumineux sur l'île des
Impressionnistes
vendredi 15 septembre jour de la saint
Roland prévoyait un ciel quelque peu
nuageux dans la matinée dans le
département le matin il fera 15 degrés
dans les secteurs de Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles et Rambouillet 14 degrés à
Houdan plein soleil l'après-midi dans
les Yvelines côté température comptait
25 degrés ce week-end la météo sera
plutôt au beau fixe sur le territoire
des éclaircies le samedi avec des
minimales à 12 degrés et des maximales à
29 degrés éclairci également le dimanche
avec des températures comprise le matin
entre 14 et 16 degrés il fera jusqu'à 28
degrés l'après-midi tout de suite
l'invité du 7 8 avec Mélanie poquet
[Musique]
les 16 et 17 septembre ce sont les
Journées européennes du patrimoine des
rendez-vous devenus incontournables sur
tout le territoire on va faire un petit
tour d'horizon sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec Lucie
Sauvageau bonjour bonjour responsable de
l'action culturelle au musée de la ville
alors Lucie cette année au niveau
national il a deux thèmes qu'on retrouve
à Saint-Quentin le patrimoine vivant et
le patrimoine du sport oui effectivement
deux thèmes cette année un peu
exceptionnels ce sont les 40 ans des
journées du patrimoine d'abord et puis
ce thème du sport forcément vient
s'ajouter au premier thème le patrimoine
vivant puisqu'il évidemment c'est
l'édition juste avant les Jeux
Olympiques quoi faire à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on a notamment
le vélodrome national qui va révéler
quelques secrets c'est ça oui c'est ça
le vélodrome national qui pouvait ouvrir
pour ses journées du patrimoine
heureusement pour nous et qui nous
permet d'avoir des visites guidées le
samedi après-midi qui permettront de
découvrir à la fois l'histoire de ce de
ce monument un dernier né des monuments
50 nuois son environnement puisqu'il est
juste à côté de de loisir sur un terrain
royal qui comportait les le réseau
d'aqueduc et de rigoles qui alimentaient
en eau le château de Versailles et puis
ça nous permet également de faire des
balades à VTT alors qu'ils seront à la
fois l'occasion d'une initiation au VTT
menée par un coach sportif et puis des
commentaires par nos guides
conférenciers sur pareil l'île de
loisirs et l'histoire de ces territoire
ça fera partie de tête des dernières
fois on pourra accéder au site avant les
Jeux Olympiques c'est probablement une
des dernières fois il y aura encore des
rencontres sportives avant les Jeux
olympiques mais par contre pour le
visiter effectivement ce sera la
dernière possibilité à noter d'ailleurs
que au même moment au même endroit se
tiendra la fête du vélo de 50 ans donc
on pourra prolonger cet amour sportif
sur l'agglomération l'agglomération il y
a le patrimoine vivant aussi le
patrimoine vivant aussi qui était aussi
un thème important de cette année donc
tous les gens qui font vivre ce
patrimoine les métiers de ceux qui
occupent ces monuments tous les jours
donc à 50 ans en Yvelines ce sera
particulièrement concentré sur les lieux
de spectacle vivant les théâtres
notamment puisque l'agglomération est
très très riche de nombreux lieux
culturels trois d'entre eux ont pu
ouvrir leur porte le théâtre scène
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines là
aussi une dernière fois vont en travaux
une dernière fois avant travaux puisque
effectivement son aspect en tout cas
extérieur va complètement être modifié à
partir de début 2024 donc pareil
dernière fois qu'on pourra le voir dans
sa configuration actuelle avec cette
façade il sera ouvert le samedi matin et
là c'est l'occasion de faire une visite
à deux voies à la fois sur
l'architecture et l'histoire de ce
monument mais aussi bien sûr les
coulisses du théâtre et la rencontre
avec les équipes techniques ce qui est
toujours passionnant oui c'est important
de mettre en avant ces personnes qu'on
peut dire de l'ombre oui absolument
qu'on voit pas souvent et vraiment qui
sont des gens passionnés et passionnants
donc ça vaut vraiment le coup c'est
toujours des visites qui sont très très
riches j'ai le théâtre Coluche aussi à
plaisir qui ouvrira ses portes voilà le
théâtre Coluche sur le dans lequel on
pourra en plus aller sans réservation ce
qui est assez donc pareil profitez-en et
qui permettra d'accéder aux coulisses de
rencontrer pareil les équipes les
techniciens autre salle le prisme il n'y
a pas que le spectacle vivant il y a
aussi le patrimoine Saint-Quentin on le
sait en regorge beaucoup le château de
la verrière qui est rarement ouvert le
château de la verrière qui est
exceptionnellement ouvert puisque c'est
le centre de formation de l'amgen donc
la Mutuelle générale de l'éducation
nationale donc il n'est pas ouvert au
public habituellement on ne peut pas le
visiter et c'est un monument en fait
qu'on ne voit que très furtivement peu
de gens savent qu'il existe mais il est
il est passionnant parce qu'il regorge
de quantité d'anecdotes historique de
tous les de tous les siècles on va du
15e siècle jusqu'au 20e et il a vraiment
il a beaucoup de de choses très
insolites à faire découvrir c'est
vraiment une belle pépite pour ces
journées du patrimoine ce genre de
journée ça permet aussi de faire
découvrir des sites qu'on peut visiter
autrement parce que je pense au château
de plaisir d'habitude c'est la
médiathèque c'est le conservatoire
il y a des secrets des petites choses
toujours à révéler qu'on peut ignorer
oui alors sur le château de plaisir là
ce sera sous forme de représentation
théâtrale plutôt qui amèneront à avoir
des informations il y a aussi une visite
en autonomie avec un votre smartphone
qui est proposé qui permet de découvrir
l'histoire des lions un petit peu
autrement et oui il y a toujours des
choses à découvrir même si on le voit
tous les jours on imagine pas souvent
l'histoire qui va derrière ces sites et
et là son parc en l'occurrence du
château de plaisir alors c'est toujours
un peu la question piège mais s'il y
avait un ou deux rendez-vous à surtout
pas noté on en a on en a dit
quelques-uns il y en a bien sûr beaucoup
d'autres dans la programmation mais si
il y avait une petite nouveauté à ne pas
manquer alors vous avez parlé du prisme
tout à l'heure et le prisme est pas
souvent ouvert pour les Journées du
Patrimoine en plus là ce sera une visite
qui sera groupée avec une visite du
quartier mais aussi de la médiathèque
des 7 mars qui est un équipement
historique de la ville nouvelle
mais pas tout de même et qui fêtera
d'ailleurs bientôt aussi ces 50 ans à la
médiathèque de cette mare et puis il y a
aussi alors une petite pépite
qui est absolument il faut réserver
absolument c'est la médiathèque de la du
patrimoine et de la photographie au fort
de Sancy ou encore la BU la bibliothèque
universitaire pareil dont on peut voir
les coulisses le fonctionnement et c'est
très intéressant il faut dépasser ce
qu'on voit quand on marche dans la rue
donc vous l'avez dit le week-end regorge
plein de plein d'autres rendez-vous rien
de plus simple pour les trouver surtout
ne pas les manquer c'est le site de
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ou du musée de
la ville merci Lucie Sauvageau j'imagine
que vous donnez rendez-vous au public
les 16 de 17 septembre tout à fait on
vous attend on sera ravi de vous
accueillir le 7 août est maintenant
terminé merci de nous avoir suivi vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission sur
notre site Internet et nos réseaux
sociaux belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]